meine damen und herren
seit anfang des jahres
treffe ich mich immer wieder mit vielen
verantwortlichen
in der regierung in einer runde die sich
mit energiefragen
beschäftigt dafür gibt es guten grund
die energiesicherheit ist ein thema dass
unser land und die ganze welt
gegenwärtig sehr bewegt und lange vor
dem ausbruch des krieges den russland
gegen die ukraine angezettelt hat haben
wir diese fragen im blick gehabt und die
notwendigen entscheidungen vorbereitet
und getroffen
wie sie wissen sind eine ganze reihe von
entscheidungen seither getroffen worden
zb das wir flüssiggas terminals an den
norddeutschen küsten bauen und pipelines
dazu errichten zum beispiel dass wir
jetzt dafür sorge tragen dass die
speicher gefüllt werden mit gesetzlichen
vorgaben die wir gerade jetzt nochmal
weiter
präzisieren und wo wir dafür sorge
tragen dass die speicher schneller
gefüllt werden müssen wir haben
überhaupt dafür gesorgt dass es eine
solche verpflichtung gibt zum beispiel
dadurch dass wir entschieden haben dass
die kohlekraftwerke wieder laufen und
uns dadurch in die lage versetzen gas
einzusparen zum beispiel dadurch dass
wir entschieden haben dass für die
transporte von kohle aufzügen auch eine
priorität eingeräumt wird und durch
viele sparmaßnahmen über diese der
bundesminister für wirtschaft gestern
informiert hat und die wir in der
regierung vorbereitet haben
heute haben wir uns mit der zukunft des
unternehmens juniper beschäftigt und
dazu auch wichtige entscheidungen
getroffen bevor ich auf diesen
konkreten fall und die konsequenzen ein
gehe will ich aber doch die prinzipien
nach denen wir handeln angesichts dieser
herausforderung für unser land und für
europa und für die ganze welt sprechen
you'll never walk alone
dass wir gemeinsam die schwierigen
zeiten bewältigen dass wir
zusammenhalten dass es entscheidend
niemand wird mit seinen
herausforderungen und problemen alleine
gelassen keine einzelne bürgerin kein
einzelner bürger auch nicht die
unternehmen in diesem land wir sind
gemeinsam stark genug das auch zu
schaffen und werden dieses und das
nächste jahr unsere probleme gemeinsam
meistern und wir werden alles
erforderliche tun
was getan werden muss damit das auch
gemeinsam gelingt und wir werden es so
lange tun wie das erforderlich ist
das unternehmen juniper ist in große
schwierigkeiten geraten ein unternehmen
das von überragender bedeutung ist für
die wirtschaftliche entwicklung unseres
landes für die energieversorgung der
einzelnen bürgerinnen und bürger aber
auch vieler unternehmen es hat was
eingekauft bei vielen die das ihm zur
verfügung gestellt haben unter anderem
auch bei gazprom und russland diese
lieferung sind wie wir alle wissen nicht
mehr sicher dass das möglich ist hat
mich schon im dezember letzten jahres
bewegt und dazu geführt dass die von mir
eben beschriebene runde zusammenkommt
und heute wieder zusammen getreten ist
um notwendige entscheidungen zu treffen
das gas das
juniper eingekauft hat und an seine
kunden weiterverkauft wird teilweise
nicht geliefert das unternehmen muss
dieses gas also zu viel höheren preisen
zu aktuellen weltmarktpreise neu
beschaffen und dadurch entsteht eine
schwierige lage für das unternehmen weil
es die preise dieses bezahlt für das gas
nicht weitergeben kann an seine kunden
und deshalb nicht in der lage ist die
finanziellen aufgaben zu bewältigen ohne
dass wir jetzt gemeinsam dem unternehmen
unter die arme greifen wir haben mit den
anteilseignern und der finnischen
regierung die an dem anteilseigner
beteiligt ist gesprochen und uns auf
eine lösung verständigt die lösung
lautet wir werden einsteigen bei juniper
mit 30 prozent anteil des unternehmens
wir werden die aktien dieses
unternehmens zum nennwert kaufen dass es
gegenwärtig ein das ist 1 70 sie wissen
dass der gegenwärtige börsenkurs über
zehn euro liegt und können sich
vorstellen dass darin ein substanzieller
beitrag der bisherigen gesellschafter
zur rettung dieses unternehmens liegt
weil sie gewissermaßen entsprechend mit
ihrem eigentum verbessert werden
gleichzeitig werden wir nicht
wandelanleihen zur verfügung stellen von
bis zu 7,7 milliarden euro als hybride
eigenkapital damit das unternehmen
sicher die herausforderung bewältigen
kann und die schon bestehende kredit
diene der kaffee von zwei milliarden auf
9 milliarden euro ausweiten alle
maßnahmen zusammen werden dazu beitragen
dass das unternehmen jetzt in der lage
ist stabil alle notwendigen
investitionsentscheidungen alle
notwendigen ein kaufentscheidung und
auch alle notwendigen entscheidungen für
die fortführung des unternehmens zu
treffen und stabil in die zukunft
blicken kann
was wir auch wissen ist dass die höheren
weltmarktpreise für energie ob das nun
kohle oder öl oder gas ist früher oder
später bei uns allen bemerkbar werden
viele haben das hierzulande schon
gemerkt die preise sind schon gestiegen
nicht nur an der tankstelle und bei der
heizung rechnung alles wird teurer wenn
man sich zu den heutigen preisen auf den
weltmärkten bedienen muss das wird
früher oder später für alle bemerkbar
sein
und deshalb haben wir jetzt schon eine
ganze reihe von maßnahmen ergriffen um
die bürgerinnen und bürger durch diese
zeit zu bringen und sie dabei zu
unterstützen ich sagte ist ja schon
niemand wird alleine in die zukunft
gehen müssen wir werden niemand mit
seinen herausforderungen alleine lassen
30 milliarden umfassende
entlastungspaket die wir bereits auf den
weg gebracht haben und da sind eine
ganze reihe von maßnahmen
festgelegt die teilweise jetzt erst
greifen am populärsten diskutiert sind
die unterstützungsmaßnahmen mit dem
neuen euro ticket und den verbilligten
preisen an den tankstellen durch
steuerverzicht für drei monate aber wir
haben auch zb die belastung des
strompreises mit der eeg umlage um über
20 milliarden euro reduziert indem wir
das in den bundeshaushalt übernommen
haben ab dem beginn des laufenden monats
wir haben darüber hinaus entschieden
dass wir steuerliche entlastung machen
die arbeitnehmer
pauschale ist angehoben worden der
grundfreibetrag angehoben worden die
pendlerpauschales angehoben worden wir
haben den wohngeldbeziehern ein
heizkostenzuschuss gezahlt werden haben
dafür gesorgt dass arme familien besser
unterstützt werden indem 20 euro mehr
pro monat für ihre kinder gezahlt werden
alle familien haben pro kind 100 euro in
aussicht gestellt bekommen und die
werden ausgezahlt wir haben dafür
gesorgt dass die grundsicherung um 200
euro angehoben wird wir haben eine
energiepreis pauschale auf den weg
gebracht und wir
wir haben durch dieses gesamte
maßnahmenbündel dazu beigetragen dass es
eine erhebliche entlastung für viele
gibt das ist auch richtig so denn die
belastung werden die habe ich eben
geschildert habe auch dauerhaft für uns
alle als bürgern und bürger als
konsumenten und konsumenten aber auch
als unternehmensführer spürbar sein und
deshalb ist sind wir uns darüber einig
dass wir auch dauerhaft weitere
entlastungen auf den weg bringen müssen
und das wollen wir auch im zusammenhang
mit den entscheidungen die wir heute
getroffen haben noch mal unterstreichen
denn zu den notwendigen maßnahmen damit
die unternehmen eine perspektive hat
gehört auch dass es ab an bestimmten
zeitpunkt seine höheren einkaufspreise
auch weitergeben kann
geplant ist jetzt zum ersten zehn
vielleicht auch etwas früher schon zum
19 je nachdem wie viel neu beschafft
werden muss kann das zu einer erhöhung
der gaspreise ums salz entführen die
dann weitergegeben werden und je nachdem
wie groß der haushalt ist wird das
durchaus auch spürbar werden dann für
die einzelnen haushalte wenn es um
bürgerinnen bürger gibt das kann schon
sagen dass damit noch einmal zusätzliche
belastungen verbunden sind die 200 oder
300 euro für eine vierköpfige familie im
jahr betragen können deshalb wie gesagt
bleibt es nicht bei den entlastungs
paketen von 30 milliarden sondern wir
werden weitere maßnahmen auf den weg
bringen und die konturen davon haben wir
in diesem zusammenhang schon einmal
miteinander besprochen und festgelegt
das erste ist es wird zum anfang des
nächsten jahres eine große
wohngeldreform geben darüber sind wir
uns in der regierung einig wir wollen
den kreis der berechtigten haushalte
ausweiten sodass mehr bürgerinnen und
bürger arbeitnehmern arbeitnehmer
rentner rentner ganz besonders die auch
davon an spar auf ansprüche haben davon
profitieren können und wir wollen in
diese wohngeldreform eine
heizkostenpauschale gewissermaßen
dauerhaft integrieren wir haben uns auch
verpflichtet wie im zusammenhang für die
studenten etwas zu tun und in ihrem
regime auch heizkostenzuschüsse mit
unterzubringen das wird jetzt im
einzelnen diskutiert und vorbereitet
die zweite große maßnahme die auf alle
fälle kommen wird ist dass wir uns dazu
verpflichten dass wir die im
koalitionsvertrag von der regierung auf
den weg vereinbarte bürgergeld reform
definitiv zum ersten januar des nächsten
jahres in kraft setzen werden die
einzelheiten werden wie sie schon
gemerkt haben jetzt miteinander
diskutiert aber das ist die grundlage
dafür dass wir eine substanzielle
entlastung derjenigen die am wenigsten
haben zustande bringen können und sie
besser stellen können das wollen wir im
einzelnen auch zustande bringen wir
werden das definitiv ergänzen indem wir
maßnahmen die wir auch schon während der
kopf 19 pandemie ergriffen haben wird
noch mal neu prüfen zum beispiel dass
wenn bürgerinnen und bürgern 1 in
schwierigkeiten haben durch die
plötzlich veränderten umstände gas strom
oder heizung zu bezahlen oder mit ihrer
miete zurechtzukommen dort in ein
rechtlicher schutz gewährt wird das
hatten wir schon einmal eingeführt und
dazu sind jetzt die zuständigen
ministerien beauftragt diese frage im
einzelnen und durchdenken und dazu
konkrete vorschläge vorzulegen
das ist das was auf alle fälle geschieht
es wird ergänzt um viele maßnahmen die
wir in der konzertierten disco aktionen
diskutieren wollen sie wissen genau dass
wir zusammen gekommen sind mit den
unternehmensverbänden mit den
arbeitgebern mit den gewerkschaften mit
der bundesbank dem sachverständigenrat
um als regierung zu diskutieren über das
was wir zu tun haben damit wir die
bürgerinnen und bürger entlasten können
damit wir wirklich wahr machen können
dass wir hier uns unterhaken und alle
gemeinsam handeln das nächste treffen
wird mitte september sein ist auch schon
eingeladen und bei diesen treffen werden
wir dann konkreter diskutieren mit all
den beteiligten dass über das hinaus was
ich eben hier skizziert habe noch zu tun
ist da gibt es viele konkrete gute
vorschläge die dann auch mit dazu
gehören dass wir eine gute
entlastung für die bürger noch bürger
organisieren können für das was für die
zukunft notwendig ist und das wird ganz
konkret dort geredet neben den maßnahmen
die dort eine rolle spielen werden wir
erneut das nutzen was wir jetzt schon an
erfahrung gewonnen haben in einer
krisenhaften situation zur
stabilisierung von unternehmen dazu
gehört zum beispiel dass wir die
kreditprogramme für unternehmen bis zu
einer gewissen größenordnung über die
kfw absichern so dass er jetzt plötzlich
hohe energiepreise hat vielleicht auch
investitionen tätigen muss um energie zu
sparen nicht wegen der schwierigen
wirtschaftlichen lage
nicht so einfach in der lage ist das
tatsächlich auch zu bewältigen deshalb
werden wir solche bürgschaften absichern
machen auch oberhalb von 80 prozent wie
wir das auch in der vergangenheit getan
haben wir werden die
bürgschaftsprogramme über das jahresende
verlängern die notwendig sind um in
dieser situation klarzukommen wir werden
dafür sorge tragen dass wir
die
möglichkeiten die wir geschaffen haben
für sehr energieintensive unternehmen
die jetzt ganz plötzlich mit sehr hohen
zusätzlichen belastungen zu kämpfen
haben die zuschuss programme die wir auf
den weg gebracht haben zu verlängern
über den monat september hinaus und wir
werden auch eigenkapitalhilfen wie wir
das jetzt am fall juni per ganz konkret
durchführen für die zukunft für
unternehmen weiter bereit denn damit
nicht systemrelevante unternehmen an den
herausforderungen dieser situation
scheitern alles zusammen eine umfassende
starke botschaft die wir hier aus senden
und ich will zurück kommen zu dem was
ich am anfang gesagt haben you'll never
walk alone
wir werden das tun was erforderlich ist
um so lange wie das notwendig ist und
wir werden als land sehr
stabil durch die herausforderung kommen
die uns angesichts des russischen
angriffskriegs auf die ukraine auf den
energiemärkten begegnen schönen dank
herr bundeskanzler ich hätte ganz gerne
gefragt ob mit dieser juni per rettung
jetzt auch ein modell geschaffen wurde
für die rettung von anderen
gasversorgern ist damit dieser lehman
effekt vor dem der wirtschaftsminister
habeck gewarnt hatte abgewendet und
können sie noch mal genau sagen bei der
weitergabe der preise der kanzler nach
seiner pressekonferenz zur aktuellen
energiepolitik und wir schalten zu
unserem bild chefreporter peter thiele
you never walk alone der kanzlei zitiert
gleich zweimal einen songtitel aus 63
ein satz der ihm offensichtlich wichtig
war niemand läuft alleine in dieser
krise niemand wird alleine gelassen ist
es das neue wir schaffen das
ja das ist so etwas ist ist ein schwur
auch wenn er natürlich auf englisch
daher kommen und nicht sonderlich schlau
ist das auf englisch zum zu machen die
botschaft die olaf scholz zwischen den
zeilen verkauft hat ist erschwert das
land darauf ein er bereitete uns alle
darauf vor das breite schichten in
diesem land breite bevölkerungsschichten
vor allem die untere mittelschicht
deutlich ärmer werden wird das massive
belastungen auf sie zukommen werden so
dass der staat sich gezwungen sieht
jetzt schon neue hilfspakete
anzukündigen wir haben ja schon ein 30
milliarden programm ein
entlastungsprogramm da war das 9 euro
ticket findet da war der tank rabatt
drin viele andere sachen auf wohngeld
andere sachen sind alle mitarbeiter
kannst alle aufgezählt und er sagt uns
eigentlich jetzt ganz deutlich das alles
reicht nicht der staat muss noch einmal
ganz ganz tief in die tasche greifen
damit die bürger ihre ihre stromrechnung
bezahlen können gas gas rechnung
bezahlen können es wird ein
bürgschaftsprogramm für die wirtschaft
gehen wir dürfen nicht vergessen wir
sind eine industrie nation und die hängt
an günstigen energiepreisen kann die
wirtschaft die energiepreise nicht mehr
bezahlen oder nicht mehr an den markt
weitergeben dann droht unser wohlstand
in bedrängnis zu geraten der kanzler hat
es gesagt wir werden auf dauer höhere
belastungen tragen müssen die politik
vor allem aber die bürger und die
wirtschaft deswegen wird ist ein
zusätzliches programm geben es wird
wieder milliarden kosten und vor allem
bereite die regierung sich darauf vor
dass man breite bevölkerungsschichten
auch rentner und studenten und leute die
arbeiten gehen auch doppelverdiener
haushalte wird auffangen müssen zum
beispiel mit einer erweiterten wohngeld
regelung mit anderen staatlichen
zuschüssen und das ist sich das ist
jetzt wirklich ein harter einschnitt und
die regierung sagt uns also leute egal
wie viel gas unser putin schickt dieser
winter wird ein harter und nicht nur der
winter sondern auch das nächste jahr das
was der kanzler jetzt gemacht hat kann
man mit fug und recht historischen oder
scholz hat aber auch gesagt wir werden
stabil durch diese energie krise kommen
durch die krise zu der ja auch die
inflation gehört nimmt ihm das ab
das ist ein versprechen und das muss er
machen erinnern wir uns ein paar jahre
zurück schuldenkrise damals ist die
damalige bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
zusammen mit dem finanzminister peer
steinbrück vor die presse gegangen und
hat den deutschen zugesagt ein sparbuch
erspartes ist sicher damals haben die
deutschen wirklich gedankt dass es an
ihr erspartes geht dass der euro
butterweich wird weil wir in
griechenland in spanien und in anderen
ländern eine fürchterliche finanzkrise
hatten damals musste man dieses
versprechen abgeben und dieses
versprechen muss man auch jetzt abgeben
und da deswegen musste der kanzler auch
nach berlin reisen das kann er nicht aus
dieser wunderschönen kulisse vor der ich
hier stehe und in nesselwang das kann ja
nicht von hier aus machen das muss er
von seinem arbeitsplatz aus machen und
wirklich um es noch einmal deutlich zu
sagen er bereitet uns darauf vor und die
und die regierung bereitet programme
forum breite bevölkerungsschichten vor
dem abrutschen in die armut zu bewahren
und er hat versprochen in niemand wird
mit seiner stromrechnung allein gelassen
und das zeigt schon die dimensionen auf
die man sich einstellen also wenn die
untere mittelschicht wenn
doppelverdiener haushalte ihre strom und
ihre heizkosten nicht mehr bezahlen
können dann ist wirklich etwas in
bewegung und man hat tatsächlich angst
davor dass wladimir putin weiter an der
preisschraube dreht weiter am gashahn
dreht und zwar nicht in richtung auf
sondern eher in richtung zu und dass
damit die krise noch mal wirklich
verstärkt wird und wir müssen durch
diesen winter kommen und die regierung
weiß jetzt und hat das uns deutlich
gesagt sie wird breite
bevölkerungsschichten durch diesen
winter bringen peter thiede aus dem
allgäu aus nesselwang uns zugeschaltet
zur pressekonferenz von olaf scholz zur
aktuellen energiepolitik und bei uns im
studio jetzt auch hans schuldige hans
jörg vehlewald bild chefreporter
politikchef nach dieser
energie-politik pressekonferenz jetzt
von olaf scholz hat er deiner meinung
nach geliefert naja hat vor allem
geliefert indem er klar gestellt hat
oder erstens das ist mein
rettungsprogramm dass es nicht das von
der wirtschaftsminister habe allein
sondern für dieses programm komme ich
extra aus dem urlaub aus dem allgäu und
ich präsentiere das euch dass das hat
sicherlich auch ein bisschen was aber
vor allem hat es die absicht den
menschen klar zu machen hier ist immer
noch der chef am kochen auch wenn
eigentlich urlaub angesagt ist das
bemerkenswerteste was ich eigentlich
eben gehört war habe ist ab dem ersten
zehn vielleicht schon ab dem ersten
september werden die teuren preise für
die mit den uni per bisher ihr gas
bezahlt hat diese mehrkosten dürfen
weiter gegeben werden an die kunden das
sind zunächst mal die stadtwerke die uni
per beliefert und diese stadtwerke
während ihr werden ihre preise dann
jetzt erstmals auch weitergeben können
an die privatkunden sie und euch und
alle die mit gas heizen und kochen und
ähnliches und das ist eine ansage
deswegen hat er auch gleich hinterher
gesagt also erstens haben wir schon
diverse
zuschüsse die wir zahlen und dann kommt
auch ab januar noch mal eine
wohngeldreform so ist es jedenfalls
geplant damit mehr menschen die jetzt
dieses wohngeld bekommen und wer immer
wie wohngeld bekommt hat dann zum
beispiel auch zuschüsse automatisch
anspruch auf die zuschüsse die jetzt
schon zugesagt sind auf diesem wege will
er dann auch die rentner die bisher
völlig leer ausgehen bei dem
heizkostenzuschuss will er die dann auch
wiederum mit hineinbringen und auch noch
die studenten also genau die
kritikpunkte die es bislang gegeben hat
rentner und studenten gehen leer aus das
will zumindest ab januar dann mit
einwohnern das wird alles wahnsinnig
teuer die frage ist natürlich ob dieser
maßnahmenkatalog reichen werde er hat ja
verschiedene scheidt entscheidung schon
angesprochen hat gesagt weitere kommen
jetzt gerade rentner studenten aber auch
familien sollen entlastet werden und
sein leitsatz war niemand wird alleine
in die zukunft gehen müssen aber reicht
das denn am ende auch na ja niemand
allein ist ja auch richtig wir sind ja
alle in einem boot muss ich auch mal
vorstellen natürlich ist das nicht geld
das von irgendwo kommt es ist
steuerzahlergeld also wir alle zahlen
dafür dass das unternehmen juni per
gerettet wird damit die weiter an uns
liefern können damit wir höhere preise
zahlen können aber eben auch weiterhin
noch sicher unser gas bekommen die
unternehmen von denen die abhänge indem
man zum beispiel bei ihnen arbeiten
werden nun aber auch wieder unterstützt
mit dem steuergeld das wir und auch die
unternehmen so gott will zahlen dass der
kreislauf wird also am gang gehalten es
sind halt keine geschenke die wir dort
englisch angeboten bekommen sondern das
geld so ist der versuch etwas das geld
wird verteilt so fair und so sinnvoll
wie möglich damit vor allem das ganze
system nicht zusammen ich fühle mich
noch mal sehr auffällig übrigens die
ankündigung auch die vorfahrt für für
kohle züge dass man also eine kohle
jetzt
gas ersetzen lässt mehr kohle weniger
gas und die vorfahrt für diese kohle
züge da weiß man
stolz in wahrheit natürlich diese kohle
züge sind im moment haben noch gar nicht
vorhanden also auch das sind noch
riesenprobleme die da vor uns liegen die
hatte alle angesprochen er hat geld
gegeben dass zumindest juniper jetzt mal
gerettet ist aber die arbeit fängt im
radio zusammen
vielen dank hans jörg vehlewald
bildpolitik chefreporter für diese
einordnung der pressekonferenz von olaf
scholz zur energiepolitik in deutschland